North Korea's nuclear threat will top
the agenda when President Trump meets
tomorrow with Chinese President Xi
Jinping overnight North Korea launched
another ballistic missile into the Sea
of Japan the new more advanced model was
first fired in February north Korea has
conducted for missile launches this year
president Trump hopes China will help
rein in Pyongyang but he warned in a
recent interview if China is not going
to solve North Korea we will Adriana
Diaz is following the latest missile
test from Beijing Adriana good morning
good morning the medium-range missile
flew about 40 miles before splashing
into the sea it comes as president Trump
and Chinese President Xi Jingping
prepare to discuss the North Korea
threat tomorrow ahead of the meeting Kim
jong-un may be sending a signal of
defiance the missile in February was
launched as Japan's leader dined with
President Trump at mar-a-lago but the
stakes are higher ahead of China's
meeting China's North Korea's largest
trading partner providing up to ninety
percent of the North's fuel supply the
US wants China to go beyond UN sanctions
and use more of its economic leverage
over Kim Jong hoon yesterday as senior
White House official said the clock has
now run out and all options are on the
table after last night's launch
Secretary of State rex tillerson in
sudan unusually terse statement saying
the US has spoken enough about North
Korea we have no further comment that no
comment generated a lot of conversation
one analyst told us it could be a
message to China ahead of tomorrow
summit that the u.s. is ready for less
talk and more action Gail thank you very
much Adriana Diaz in Beijing reporting
this morning